eu quero começar contando pra vocês uma
antiga história uma história milenar da
tradição sufi e que nos fala sobre
alguns peixes que ouviu falar de uma
substância maravilhosa de algo
extraordinário que poderia dar a eles
tudo que eles precisassem toda saúde
bem-estar prosperidade
tudo aquilo que eles quisessem na vida
eles ficaram tão encantados sobre isto
que eles quiseram saber o que era e
contaram eles é água
eles então começaram a procurar a compor
toda parte e eles saíram buscando a água
e convocando outros peixes para esta
busca os outros peixes entusiasmados por
esta mesma busca idéia
começaram então a fazer os seus grupos
de busca cada um buscando do seu jeito
cada um tentando da sua forma cada um
tentando fazer dada sua busca e do seu
meio um jeito de alcançar essa tal de
água que se falava
mas esses peixes que originalmente tinha
ouvido falar sobre essa história não
estavam convencidos com nenhum dos
métodos utilizados por que alguns dos
peixes
acharam que o melhor da se reúnem em
grupos construir grandes catedrais e ali
a tentar descobrir o que é essa tal de
água era outros pensado que o negócio
era fazer grandes academias grandes
projetos de pesquisa e descobrir o que é
essa tal de agüero
outro achado que não era nada disso e aí
e se isolaram no fundo do mar e como
eremita procuraram compreender por si
mesmo que essa tal de água era mas
aqueles peixes originais que buscavam
estavam convencidos de nada disso
ouviram falar de um velho sabe o peixe
que morava muito longe dizia se sabia o
que é o tal de água é ver esses peixes
então navegam por muitos males chegam
neste lugar encontro este velho sabe o
peixe perguntam nos digam por favor nos
diga por favor o que é a água
recife fábio pai peixe ela sabe mesmo
morre de rir e disse vocês estão vendo a
água é tudo que você já tem é o de vocês
estão é aquilo que os faz livros
eles ficam decepcionados
então a água não é tudo isso que nos
falaram não é aquilo que pode nos dar
tudo que nós precisamos que pode
oferecer toda em toda nossa prosperidade
bem-estar felicidade saúde
ele diz é a água exatamente isso mas nós
não compreendemos
nós não estamos vivendo isto e o sábio e
velho peixe disse tudo bem é que vocês
ainda não conseguiram se dar conta de
que já estão vivendo aquilo que buscam
então convidaram ele convidou esses
peixes a hola a pular e quando eles
passassem acima da linha da água eles se
encontrarem um outro elemento e quando
ele se encontrasse esse outro elemento e
se entenderiam melhor do que essa tal de
água ela os peixes começam a pular a
pular e alguns passam pela linha da água
chegam ao ar sentem que vou morrer que
aquilo tá difícil que eles não conseguem
viver ali eles voltam pra você tem
aquele bem estar profundo aquela
completude aquela plenitude aquele senso
de realização e alguns estamos felizes
sim sim eu compreendi
eu tive uma experiência transcendental
esta história pode nos conduzir no
entendimento desta busca múltipla que
nos faz entender e compreender e
mergulhar cada vez mais fundo naquilo
que já somos na inteligência que já nos
habita na condição que já está
disponível
talvez um dos aspectos que nós podemos
começar nessa diversidade religiosa
entender que quem sabe nossa religião
seja a busca de nós mesmos mas aí nós
vamos colecionar histórias a respeito
dessas questões e ovídio um rabino
cabalista e tela vive quando ele
começava em palestra a seguinte
expressão sua crença em deus é
irrelevante e eu pensei nossa
um rabino a um rabino em tel aviv
falando isso que coisa interessante e
ele continuou dizendo pois deus se
manifesta através das leis que regem a
vida ea morte
você não controla estas leis você apenas
as experimenta é como dizer que você não
acredita na lei da gravidade
se você saltar de um prédio de 20
andares
você vai perceber que a sua crença
irrelevante a é preciso que a gente
compreenda portanto que independente da
crença que nós temos sobre a realidade
transcendente que nos perpassa a esta
crença em relevante porque essa
realidade nos perpassa nós nascemos e
nós morremos e isto é a condição disse
estarmos nesse ambiente existencial que
faz toda a diferença
dizem os sábios chineses a de uma outra
tradição que vai nos convidar então a
repensar sobre nossa trajetória a pra
que a gente possa compreender mais um
pouco da religião comum a todos nós diz
esses sábios que a vida a existência é
uma ponte entre o nascimento ea morte
não construa seus castelos na ponte
ponte foi feita pra passar não foi feita
pra ficar assim aproveite a paisagem
carpini é preciso que a gente se dê
conta portanto que talvez o outro
aspecto da religião comum a todos nós é
que nossa religião pode ser o
entendimento da existência abrir o livro
da vida a e todos os dias
contribuir com essa grande história
fazer esta grande diferença quando nós
fomos passear por muitas tradições nós
vamos ver muitos espaços de sabedoria
sendo apresentados neste grande esquema
da diversidade que nos une numa mesma e
única expressão no desejo absoluto de
uma realização de uma
felicidade de um bem spahn então nós
abrimos o livro egípcio dos mortos e
vamos ter lá um grande roteiro aqui falo
da morte mas é um grande roteiro da vida
porque disse os egípcios que quando o
indivíduo morre ele deseja ir para a
ilha dos deuses que uma espécie de
paraíso para os egípcios um nirvana
egípcia ano e eles desejam ir para a
ilha dos deus onde habitam todos os dias
onde a vida é fantástica esse indivíduo
precisa fazer um bar de uma travessia e
é um barqueiro que vai levá lo e se
marquinhos vai fazer duas perguntas ea
primeira pergunta é a sua vida te fez
feliz e se a resposta do indivíduo for
não ele não vai habitar a ilha dos
deuses mas como combinar que ninguém
precisa morrer pra ser expulso do
paraíso se a sua vida não te faz feliz
você já está exilado da ilha dos deuses
ou seja está fora do paraíso
então esta pergunta pra ser solicitada
desde já em todos os dias mas o
indivíduo de sim o barquinho então vai
fazer uma segunda pergunta ea segunda
pergunta é sua vida fez outras pessoas
felizes
se a resposta for não o indivíduo não
vai poder e perda dos deuses de novo
acredito que esse é o roteiro pra gente
entender se evitamos um não o paraíso da
existência porque se nossa vida não faz
outras pessoas felizes nós já estamos
exilados do nirvana existencial
assim a resposta quando vinha 152 cinza
esse indivíduo podia pra ele nos deu se
a gente pensa acabar os testes que nada
no livro chips dos mortos os testes não
param nunca é uma coisa que vai de 1 de
um para o outro e cada estágio
aumentando o nível de consciência do
indivíduo mas eu vou falar da terceira
tarefa que eu considero fundamental para
chegarmos a um elemento outro elemento
de unidade na diversidade religiosa que
todos temos que é a pergunta que totti o
deus da sabedoria ou teste que torna o
deus da sabedoria vai fazer com esse
duvido que está fazendo sua passagem a
uma grande balança a com dois pratos
muito grandes e totti recolhe o coração
do indivíduo coloca num dos pratos dessa
balança e do outro lado no outro prato a
uma pena e este coração não pode pesar
mais do que uma pena se não o indivíduo
nem desce volta no mesmo barco
é interessante a gente pensar sobre isto
porque se o nosso coração pesa mais do
que uma pena a gente realmente não pode
ficar no paraíso
nós precisamos de um coração leve nós
precisamos de uma capacidade de olhar
para a vida de uma forma que tem a
leveza e isso significa trabalhar do
estado do perdão perdão a uma palavra
latina que é vem do prefixo per que é
perene permanente do ar que abrir mão
perdoar é abrir mão permanentemente não
deixar nada grudado em nós
assim perdoar nunca teve a ver com o
outro sempre te ver conosco
tem gente que não perdoa até que já
morreu e significa que a questão nunca
foi com o outro sempre foi com a gente
mesmo então tornar-se leve tornar-se
livre e talvez um outro elemento que nós
podemos pensar é que a nossa religião
seja a da leveza e aí nós vamos
percebendo que todas as produções vão
expressando questões que são a busca de
toda a humanidade vai rolar a um profeta
fundador da fama ray
ele vai dizer que um sintoma básico da
paz ea gentileza que quando nós saímos
da gentileza porque nós saímos da paz e
interessante que a gente possa pensar
portanto que uma expressão máxima da
nossa paz seja o cultivo permanente da
nossa gentileza para com todos para com
tudo e para com nós mesmos e talvez nós
podemos dizer então que nossa religião
também é a gentileza da nossa religião
pode ser a gentileza e nós vamos
perceber do que nessa
diversidade de interesses de idéias
divisões
atenta às coisas que a gente vê e diz
mas com isso eu também me identifico
isso também fala em meu nome
isso também convoca meu coração isso
também faz da vida
há uma sintonia com a minha vida
passando por outra tradição nós vamos
ouvir as histórias dos mestres toltecas
que vão nos dizer que a vida é um sonho
é um sonho de humanidade e havia uma
primeira aldeia que sonhava a vida
mas se essa vida não era muito boa até
que 10 ou de nascer um sábio e este
sábado então ele sonhou um sonho de uma
humanidade muito melhor
ele ensinou as pessoas estes este sonho
e todos então aprendendo este sonho
passado a conviver em grande harmonia
paz e bem aventurança mas eu disse sabe
morreu e as pessoas desta comunidade
passaram a ensinar os seus filhos aquilo
que tinham aprendido porém esqueciam
alguma coisinha aqui outra coisinha lá
na geração seguinte muitas coisas se
esqueceram até que dizem os mestres
toltecas que a humanidade iria se
esquecer do som original e haveria de
nascer mais um sábio que pudesse então
recontada humanidade este sonho
por isso os avatares por isso os
profetas de tantos tempos mas dizem os
mestres toltecas que cada um de nós é
também um que desperta para ouvir o
sonho e ser capaz de reproduzir na
realidade ser capaz de colocá lo em
prática então nós podemos dizer que há
também pra nós todos uma religião dos
sonhadores que nós somos indivíduos que
sonhamos com a bem aventurança de um
mundo melhor de algo que pode nos
inspirar para coisas melhores para
tempos melhores
há tantas possibilidades religiosas mais
uma só convocação uma transformação
aquilo que percebemos daquilo que somos
e daquilo que vivemos em algo
profundamente melhor que a gente possa
entregar pra vida algo que faz da vida
um campo mais florido uma experiência
mais pacífica um estado de maior da
morosidade e talvez nós possamos dizer
então que nossa religião é o amor que o
amor pode nos inspirar a todos podem nos
guiar a todos pode nos ensinar a todos
acolher a todos sem distinção e quando
eu digo todos eu digo todos os mesmos
todos os seres em todas as dimensões
é preciso que a gente compreenda que o
verdadeiro espírito do religare não é
algo que nos separa quando nós
percebemos as diferentes expressões mas
é algo que nos convoca a unidade a
integridade ea absoluta afinidade com
tudo aquilo que é vivo e que pulsa vida
em nós e vida no planeta
nós somos gaia nós habitamos gaia nós
pertencermos à gaia
nós podemos dizer que a nossa religião
ea vida e assim com tantos aspectos de
uma mesma e profunda religião viva é
preciso que a gente aprenda mesmo a
compartilhar no tempo da nossa
resistência aquilo que de melhor a gente
tem a oferecer
que sejamos capazes de perfumar a vida
com os nossos sorrisos que sejamos
capazes de espalhar a nossa gentileza
que sejamos capazes de aceitar aquilo
que é pelo que é e não por nossos
julgamentos mas mais que todo
compreender uma visão de pr vai o que é
o primeiro reitor e fundador da
universidade internacional da paz unipaz
ele disse que a fonte de todo o conflito
é nossa ilusão de separar a atividade é
imaginarmos que nós estamos efetivamente
separados uns dos outros e entre os
muitos ecossistemas esta ilusão gera
conflito dentro e fora de nós
nós saímos dessa ilusão
despertarmos para novas potencialidades
nós seremos capazes de unificar todos os
seus aspectos da religião e nós a
gentileza a integridade o amor à vida e
expressar mos isto na prática do bem
viver do bem fazer um bem cuidar de um
prosperar coletivo é preciso que
compreendamos que o chamado é individual
para uma tarefa coletiva cada um de nós
aqui atender esse chamado aqui ouvir
aquilo que à sua própria vocação
há claramente nós uma diversidade algo
que nos faz únicos e peculiares mas isto
não é uma separação é uma
complementaridade é porque todos somos
absolutamente necessários que estamos
juntos neste mesmo tempo e neste mesmo
planeta
é claro que entre nós há alguns que já
despertaram o interesse de fazer com que
estas esta unidade se de e eu percebo
que há algum tempo
nós éramos considerados loucos e éramos
muito poucos
eu vejo hoje que nós ainda somos loucos
mas já não somos tão poucos que bom
gratidão